[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
imagine if I just kept humming like that
pretending as if I didn't know it was on
oh ladies and gentlemen
it is 8 30. I started I was ready to
roll I started the countdown a little
late but
might as well just let it go now but
welcome everyone welcome
give the give the folks who run in a
little bit late give them just a couple
more minutes you know
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I know dude everybody always compliments
the music
I need to find a couple more honestly a
couple more
playlists that we could pick from
you know what I should start doing I
I should start getting here
I mean I'm obviously I'm here I have to
hit the go live button to start it at
the 10 minute mark But I should
immediately just start going through
the names that way we don't have to do
that right when we start because as soon
as we you guys are I mean you guys
always show up like crazy before we even
before we even go live so thank you for
that we got soundtrack here we got royal
blue Nico is in the house one of our
moderators here skylines music Ashley
Sonic Ranger number one not the number
two not the number three ladies and
gentlemen the number one Sonic Ranger in
the house Macy is back with us once
again as well Channel member here uh
Kieran is here another Channel member
Jason Hodges o g v in the house tonight
fandom draws is back with us again man I
can't tell you it means so much to see
so many of the same names returning back
thank you guys so much
uh Dylan in the house another moderator
and channel member here Draco
but not like Draco Malfoy d-r-a-k-o
[Music]
Amore poet is here again I'll be late
tonight popping in to say hi I'll be
back sounds good sounds good
Shadow guided another Channel member is
here Jenny is here Dr sherbet is here
stream elements ladies and gentlemen the
stream element spot that seems kind of
Hit or Miss for YouTube honestly
some things it works some things it
doesn't it's the weirdest thing
I saw Dylan uh plugging the merch thank
you for that Dylan I I have a command
that I have
let's see if it's gonna work tonight
we'll try
I have a command that I have set up in
stream elements to wear exclamation
point merge should take you to it but
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
so actually I've never seen that command
work but the other commands seem to work
Robin is here Gator fan Tokyo retro guy
gaming welcome retro guy
another Channel member here as well also
Shadow guided a channel member
[Music]
I have my desk in my
in the standing position tonight so you
guys are going to see a slightly
different background you ready for this
boom
oh wait you know what we usually go
we usually go full cam first
darn it we usually go full cam first see
so we got like
tonight you can actually see
the items that I have well at least some
of them you can't see all of them
and then I've also been working on the
backdrop for over here
actually I can probably show you this
with the camera let me tilt this camera
down
Jenny yo Jenny thank you so much
becoming a channel member
now you get access to those slick new
emotes Logan a channel member as well
did somebody gift some did I miss a
gifted or did we did we just have back
to back
channel members there that's awesome
how are you welcome what
what is happening Vic big becoming a
channel member as well V thank you so
much
[Music]
okay somebody had to give some right oh
there we go somebody gifted Ravenclaw
Tyrell gifted five memberships Plum Bob
Kingdom got one of the memberships as
well as Jacob Peterson right there
Jacob congratulations congrats to all
five of you who just got Channel member
are you kidding me
five
[Music]
oh wait Christy's back Christy is back
and gifting memberships as well
Christy gifting a membership low okay
Logan was actually I think Logan was a
member
okay there we go right now it popped up
I don't know why the memberships popped
up first normally the gift pops up first
but thank you guys so much
thank you all so much for uh showing
your support of the channel in that way
you get access now to what I think are
some pretty cool Emoji you also get some
discounted merch as well if you go to
the uh Channel member page
or the uh I think it's called the
Community page all right I'm gonna turn
down the music Just a Touch now
so we can have it just a little bit more
in the background actually I might just
need to turn it down yeah more on my
side than anything
[Music]
there we go that's right
oh man thank you guys so much welcome to
another live stream oh yeah what was I
doing I was gonna try to show you guys
the uh
so I got this slick new webcam that has
so much customization with it all right
so we're gonna try to tilt down
so you guys can see so I'm like I'm kind
of building up this area over here
whoops wrong way
see we got we got the little uh we got
the Harry Potter item there
see how well the zoom works right here
there we go so we got okay here we go so
we got coal from Infamous
Morgana persona 5.
you guys should know this one
you guys should know this one for sure
we got Samus here amiibo if you're
wondering where the x is it's like on
the other side of my room I have it for
uh these little coasters right here so
this is a work at progress but
eventually I don't know maybe a Hogwarts
like Z collector's edition will rest
right here
we'll see we'll see
if you look at that then I can just
instantly Zoom it right back to where I
want it it's a pretty slick camera I'm
liking it so far
I never liked the uh I actually had
I think it was a DSLR it was like one of
the nicer Sony ones you know not not
like break the bank but not like super
budget either kind of mid-tier you're a
wizard and it was just so bulky and
just so bulky so many wires that I
missed the just the ease of use of a
webcam and so I was like with as little
as I I mean for live streams you don't
need like super high quality webcam
webcam you just need a decent webcam and
this one will actually do 4K as well I'm
on just 1920 by 1080 right now but
all right so let's get caught up here we
have Scarlett Scarlet girl 27 is back
another Channel member Chris is here as
well let's see we already shouted out
Robin we got yaction assassin back with
us uh let's see we got Gator fan already
Scarlet is here Jagged wizard Jagged
welcome
second stream too for Dr Sherman yeah I
remember your your name last time
because whenever I was a kid that word
people always pronounced it sherbert
like there was an r in there
maybe it was just growing up in
in the South where I grew up I don't
know but I it's it's sherbet right is
that how I mean that's I feel like
that's the
correct pronunciation
Caesar becoming a channel member as well
guys you have the channel memberships
are insane we have unlocked
actually let me check right now let me
check right now
because I just we just unveiled all
those new emoji and I already think
we've unlocked at least three more slots
and I think we're getting pretty close
to a fourth slot
so let me go here and check real quick
memberships it's in such a weird spot
where you go to find it uh customize
default perks there we go Emoji Okay so
we've unlocked one two three we've
unlocked three more emo slots and we are
seven members away that might have been
before tonight's stream though before we
counted all these but it says we're
seven away from another Emoji so
I gotta have uh I gotta reach back out
to this designer because we're gonna
need we're gonna need some more emoji
thanks to your old support
so I definitely want one
for some type of wave emoji so if you
guys have any ideas at all for a Harry
Potter slash Hogwarts Legacy inspired
wave emoji
so right now we've got a laughing how
self looks pretty similar to Dobby but
just laughing house self we've got an
angry Voldemort
we've got the symbol of the Deathly
Hallows we've got icons for each of the
four houses and
there's one more Merlin Viet Merlin
daddy Merlin is there in the house
feathers Channel member is here C.W
Evans is back with us as well Sly the
auror nicely I know dude everybody
always compliments the music I wish I
could claim I wish it was mine
Christy here some random person was
there Hogwarts I can see a leak no not a
leak
not a leak
just a uh new Instagram post
its philosophy is here Hannah is here
you say the orange Sherbert okay
maybe maybe it is supposed to be
pronounced that way I don't know
oh and my chat just did that thing where
it jumped really far so I think I missed
some of you
so you now have to scroll back up oh
dude right don't you love this the
silver
one of my favorite controllers of all
time the wave bird
oh I mean even even now this is what I
was playing uh Prisoner of Azkaban with
on the GameCube even now this controller
is just instantly it's so comfortable
man so comfortable obviously it doesn't
have the triggers that we need
for most modern games but the comfort of
that controller is unmatched I don't
know why Nintendo went away I thought
this was a great idea with the buttons
now everybody goes with just keeping the
buttons all the exact same size but I
thought it was a great idea to actually
base it around
you know the button that you use most
often why not make that a bigger one
right
I thought it was a good idea
clearly Nintendo didn't because they
didn't they didn't stick with it
I am standing Ravenclaw Terrell yeah
that's why that's why we're up a little
higher here
Dylan gifting another five channel
memberships are you kidding me ladies
and gentlemen
star Hopper
I love this part though I'd love
I love after you get the gift of members
like wait let's see who's gonna get it
who gets the gift of memberships no caps
also getting one of the channel
memberships guys if you get one of these
Channel memberships make sure you thank
the person uh who gifted them we had
Christy give some already we had uh
Ravenclaw it's a Rel gifted some we had
uh or Caesar actually became a member on
their own so yeah just make sure you
check who gifted it to you how are you
make sure you thank them for showing
showing the support and and spreading
the love around Hannah got one of those
memberships as well
how are you welcome to great it's
philosophy with another Channel
membership
we'll see one more
you're a wizard Harry oh
that threw me off we got a sub in there
welcome to the new Subs as well I've
seen a couple people subscribing to the
channel
also
all right we got Levi back in the house
new store hey I recognize that name
olimar92 no just getting started just
getting started Jenna JP raven fire is
here as well JP dude so if you guys
didn't see our we had both a tweet and a
sponsored video
first big sponsorship guys and it was
none other than Jam City with Harry
Potter Hogwarts mystery so we're also
doing a contest
or a sweepstakes I think is technically
what we have to call it so if you play
Harry Potter Hogwarts mystery or if you
download it using my link which all this
information is on my actually you know
what let's go and pull this up JP
ravenfire I knew I recognized your name
because JP raven fire was uh one of the
first to enter this contest so I'm
giving away a 25 Amazon gift card all
you have to do is play at least until
you get sorted in the game
screenshot your character getting sorted
and then send it to me on Twitter and
you'll be entered to win now if we hit
200 downloads using the little code that
I'm about to show you then I'll give
away a second Amazon card and that's the
sweepstakes is all me that's like the
giveaway stuff that's me that's not Jam
City so that's something that they they
suggest but they don't they don't
sponsor that and I thought you know what
we just hit 30 000 Subs on on uh YouTube
it would be a good time to give back to
the community so let's go ahead and pull
this up here
if we go to my
twitter.com retro wrecking tour
so let's see here we go right here
so there's the code iOS or Android
jamcity dot me slash HP hm retro
and then you can be entered to win you
just uh like I said screenshot yourself
getting sorted
shoot it to me on Twitter but yeah as
soon as I saw your name JP it made me
think about that
all right star Hopper gifted some as
well oh yeah thank you starhopper
someone else gifted five someone else
gifted one someone else joined
themselves oh right oh you were yeah you
were explaining through it there
Logan's like I joined right before all
the gifted started coming in
oh yeah Dylan and Nico there showing off
the Emoji Christy as well so you guys
can see them
do you have to be able to to pay to be a
member so on YouTube they use sort of a
different terminology memberships yes
memberships are the paid
just a way if you want to throw monetary
support to the channel completely
optional never feel obligated our
community here is like always
ridiculously generous with the channel
memberships but I don't want anybody to
ever think that you have to be a member
or anything
um I do try and give some fun little
perks for those who do choose to show
their support in that way so one of them
are the Emoji that you can use in chat
here another one is a discount on merch
another one is you get like priority
reply on comments so dude Bradley with a
super chat a 10 super chat
no question at all
Bradley dude was that just a donation or
did you mean to have a a question with
that thank you so much Bradley
if you don't don't if you did have a
question that didn't get included you
don't have to donate again I will scroll
through and find it thank you so much
Bradley
very much appreciate that if you had a
question I'd be happy to to try and
answer it though but it did not show up
on my end but it did show it did show
the ten dollars so thank you very much
for that but yeah so on YouTube
subscriptions are free so you can sub to
the channel for free that's a great way
to show support uh that costs nothing at
all it's just it's just basically hey I
enjoy your channel I'm gonna sup I'm
gonna throw you a little love
and honestly even the way YouTube Works
nowadays the subs don't mean nearly as
much as they used to
because the way the subscription feed
and all that works but I I still man I
want that I want that uh 100K
subscribers
right here right here I want to save
that for the 100K subs and who knows who
knows maybe one day we'll have a 1
million one there but 100K like that one
that's attainable you know
30k Subs it's like okay
we were just starting out trying to get
a hundred Subs on on uh YouTube that
seemed very like there's no way but now
30k hey you can kind of you kind of
start to see it there Levi becoming a
channel member as well as CW Evans
Becoming a channel member and then Elwyn
Elwyn just gifted five more memberships
holy cat well we definitely just
we just blew past the goal I think we
needed seven more to get a new Emoji now
how are you welcome guys thank you so
much dude the the support I mean we have
we haven't even started talking Hogwarts
Legacy yet
started talking about
that we're just we're just sitting here
chilling out listening to music
[Music]
all right here we go rapid fire now
Levi's here and that Levi just gotta I
think Levi got one of the gifteds there
Dylan smash that like button for our
favorite dad who loves games and the
stories they tell hey thank you guys so
much for showing love with the like
button
God's Wrath against Cole McGrath oh are
you not a not an Infamous fan yeah the
Persona cat yep
[Music]
you're a wizard I'm doing well okay I
pulled up
just me or yep never mind Jake another
Channel member welcome back Jake IDK
Channel member is here in the house as
well
you butchered the name you know Dr
sherbet
Sherbert yeah everybody like growing up
where I grew up everybody always said
sherbert
I I don't know you know what now I'm
like
why have I never looked this up no not
web set what are you what are you
talking about Webster's
okay so Miriam Webster
let's see
all right I'm gonna mute the music for
you guys
so we can all hear this
here it is here it is once and for all
sherbet
sherbet sherbet sherbet sherbet
it sounds so weird it doesn't sound
correct but Sherbert doesn't sound
correct either
although you know what sherbet lemon
McGonagall McGonagall remember that
[Music]
extra
extra white welcome Scott L can't
remember how to get membership on
YouTube live so
let me see if we'll see if this command
works
I haven't even gotten down to the point
where I initially put that command I'm
probably like 10 minutes behind now you
guys have already moved on you're
talking
I don't know about something completely
different now
maybe Hogwarts Legacy or something the
the game that we're hanging out to talk
about
oh goodness all right
Bradley Roberts is here as well Midwest
does that too fandom draws
foreign
okay it must be a thing I don't know
where it got started
it doesn't particular matter so long you
should pronounce the first R okay gotcha
Kieran you're just imagining me being
here I don't blame you amazing wait what
Ravenclaw Tyrell I can only make it to
your lives what do you mean
you can only make it to the lives
its philosophy loved catching a retro
stream when I can't sleep Big Love from
the UK hey oh it's it's really late in
the UK
Gabe here in the house need an evil
poppy Emoji I feel like that's James's
thing you know expect he'll go
how do you get membership on mobile on
mobile it's in kind of a weird spot I
think you have to go to the main Channel
page
and then it's at the top I believe
oh my gosh I'm so behind
I'm so behind every everyone here is
gonna be a member soon right
wishing you a speedy recovery oh no is
somebody not feeling well fandom draws
could you all pray for me I'm slowly
recovering from covid really nauseous
right oh yikes well Phantom I I am a
believer in in the power of prayer so
whether you guys are praying people or
send your good thoughts Good Vibes
whatever it may be
send your send your love to fandom draws
here
it's tough man it like it hits people in
different ways it really does some
people have a really hard time
recovering for it especially if you have
some sort of uh
previous condition or anything but man I
had it back in
late February March and I didn't have
any long-term effects but dude I was I
mean it was like a really bad flu for me
for a week
Jay creel or maybe it's JC real two
three four first time watching live
wonder how well this run on Steam deck I
I've been getting that question a lot
I'm curious to see and I'm curious to
see if they'll say anything beforehand
as well
Macy let him know how to
oh if you're only mobile browser enable
show his desktop then you should be able
to do it
nice
I'm a Gryffindor Gator fan
oh here's a name I'm gonna struggle to
pronounce okay
you're a wizard Harry Kayla Tara Kayla
Tara
not gonna try the last name Kayla Tara
says what's up welcome Kayla Tara thank
you for being here tonight
I don't think I've ever seen the name
elwin and Elwyn just randomly gifting
five subs or five memberships elwin for
real thank you so much CW Evans Becoming
Channel member I see CW in here all the
time dude CW always showing the Love on
Twitter as well good of you to be here
CW
all right we're getting close now we're
getting close we got uh
Shadow guided wait what you got to go
back to the hospital on Friday oh no
like you have to go back to the hospital
Shadow guided
I mean I don't know how much you're
comfortable saying so whatever but
whatever it is you know hospitals
usually never good unless it's for
I guess like
I don't know like a birth of a child
that's really
it's a I've had two kids now and we're
we're done we're good with our two
barring any you know something uh
completely unplanned but yeah it's like
hospitals have such that such a weird
feel and when you're there for a baby
it's
there's nervousness around the birth of
a child because there's sadly so much
that can go wrong but it's like such a
joyful experience compared to if
everything goes well compared to when
most time you know I don't hospitals say
I mean does anybody like being in a
hospital right it's one of those things
that it's just nobody really likes to
have to be such a strange feeling my
wife is a nurse so she she works in the
hospital Melissa is back as well I
recognize that name hi IQ Warrior how's
it going dude
Pedro is here as well
if you are a gifted member do you have
to pay for it uh no Levi yeah that's the
person that gifted it to you they paid
for you to be a member for one month
basically yeah
DJ we can get seven more of we've
already we've we're way past the seven
more
soundtrack do not feel obligated all
seriously seriously like
just hanging out and honestly
chatting being a supporter of the
channel is more than enough support more
than enough
star Hopper I definitely think so yeah I
think asmrs I think for sure we're gonna
get two more
now defeat the point of the gift right
right
CW I am that was one quote I remember
from the game oh wait I didn't see what
quote
see this is how far behind I am I don't
even know what they're talking about now
oh goodness I really need to do my I I
need to do the idea of when I hit go
live we start the 10 minute countdown I
just immediately start welcoming
everyone
that way as soon as we go live live like
this
then we'll be ready to start chatting
start uh answering questions and things
[Music]
that's like 19 today oh my gosh dude
that's incredible
yeah be sure you guys uh say thanks to
those of you who got
we've got a gifted membership
just got off work nice to catch another
stream nice listening to Hagrid I know
right when he when he pops up for the
Euro wizard Henry
Tristan how soon is soon
for what exactly
yeah I think the next ASMR I think it
will probably be
well let's see because we did they
haven't done a fall video so they got to
do fall before winter and we're already
like we're officially in Fall now I
think it was Dylan last week asking
somebody was asking if I thought they
were going to do one like that week and
I said nah it's too soon after all the
big announcements
so I think we'll probably get a fall one
in the
I don't know maybe the November time
frame
and then a winter one in January before
the release or they could do early
February
first time watching live wonder how well
oh yeah I already read that one
T dark vein thanks for covering all this
for so long hey dude thank you for
supporting the channel it's uh I gotta
be honest with you I never
I didn't think it was going to be this
long because when I first started
covering Hogwarts Legacy
it was slated for
oh my gosh okay when did I
so they announced in 2020.
and said it was going to come out in
2021 so I started covering it at the
tail end of 2020. yeah and I remember
thinking oh this will be a good year
of making videos on this game
making videos on other games and who
knows what'll happen well
the game got delayed
so it got delayed for a full year which
ended up being like two years you're a
wizard Harry crazy man but yeah I've
I've loved it I've loved every minute of
it
it's been very strange to go from having
like no news to having so much news
lately
fireborn I'm on PC prompt isn't showing
to enable gifts okay so you won't see
the prompt from what I've been told you
won't see the prompt to accept unless
you're gifted one
and I don't believe there are any
I don't believe there are any um ways to
choose on YouTube I don't think you can
choose who gets the gifted membership
on the purple platform you can I think
you can actually pick or you can make it
random
hey Dylan thanks for hanging out dude
good to see you
have to be on the replay squad for this
one
okay there we go so the exclamation
point join Works no problem
sherbet just sounds weird right
it does
hey how's it going right oh toothache
yeah
he are really painful
okay later what's the book I know right
we're about to get into it here
sherbet is a form of sugar ah
interesting
most anticipated spell
well it's not confirmed but expecto
patronum if it's in
if it's in
what's happening Thursday Jake
Elle went only here for a short time
before my dog oh I do remember somebody
talking about dog training last week did
you change your name or something
I don't remember the name Elwyn but I
definitely remember somebody talking
about dog training
Christy can't keep up switched something
about my oh it but Chad just did that
thing where it jumps again
oh man
[Music]
okay hold on
[Music]
oh my gosh Christy you're in Florida
where the storms are
yikes I have some family in Florida but
they're they're kind of to the Northwest
like in the Panhandle which
I haven't checked the latest to see how
bad it's gonna get there oh you had hand
surgery a week ago Shadow guided
[Music]
so you got to go back in for like a
follow-up or something maybe
well I hope everything goes well
foreign
[Music]
back up
I'm so far ridiculously behind
oh it would be great drummer if it came
out around Christmas
[Music]
oh I see what you mean Ravenclaw last
week was the first live expecto I could
make he did a late stream oh gotcha
gotcha
Ray is here in the house as well larg
brand welcome welcome guys
do you think we'll get a Hogwarts Legacy
demo
don't think so
I don't think so
[Music]
maybe after the game's been out for a
bit
but I don't think so before launch
Slytherin we are the best
uh is the Spellbook unofficial or
unofficial or official
I don't know if I think Ryan's joking
because uh
he's putting me in a bind here
because it is from an official Source
the post was
but yeah for all you were stabbed in the
hand a while back so surgery was needed
oh my goodness Shadow guided
that is insane
yikes I hope everything goes well that
is crazy
[Music]
all right I'm making an executive
decision here guys I've gotta I'm just
gonna have to scroll up
I'm just gonna have to scroll through if
I missed your comment my apologies
I'm caught up now though I'm all the way
at the uh at the end
my apologies I did as I was scrolling
through there quickly somebody said uh
somebody complimented the videos and
asked me what I do in my regular day job
so I work for a library a public library
in marketing I used to work for them in
like a teaching role I taught classes on
Tech
tech classes such as Photoshop
illustrator video editing all those
kinds of things but then for about the
past year I've been working in marketing
yeah
foreign
[Music]
I'm caught up now Kayla tar I'm so far
behind been stabbed three times what
oh my goodness
that is insane
oh wait it's sure we get timed out for
something
stream elements has got a weird
stream elements is behaving very
strangely on YouTube live streams
all right all right all right
everybody's ready everybody's ready to
get to this
Okay so
I gotta be honest I'm a little upset
with Chandler wood
I'm a little upset with him you guys
I didn't even know about the thanks to I
follow you know expecto go and been snow
all those folks on Twitter who also
cover the game but
I hadn't even seen this and I saw James
tweeted this today
what the heck is he talking about here
like what is this
and so here's my I posted Chandler was
this only shared on Instagram Chandler
don't do this to me please I can't have
another platform I need to keep up with
so I do have an Instagram I very rarely
post on it you guys are more than
welcome to follow if you want but so I
had to go into my Instagram which I very
rarely use and I had to find what the
heck they're talking about here so
today's post
this right here guys an Instagram only
post
for Hogwarts Legacy Instagram only
so this was not as far as I know they
still haven't shared this on Twitter I
don't know about Facebook because I
hardly ever look at Facebook
so let's start with the post here and
then there are also three little
sections to this so here's the text
don't tell the Headmaster
consider this an unauthorized guide to
Student Life at Hogwarts
foreign
and then we can see this book right here
I'm going to pause at this next time
right there
and
button oh nope I want you to pause right
there okay
so we can see the H here
we can see the school Crest in behind it
and I think
possibly an m
you know James had to see an M right
away James had to see an m
uh James is thinking Merlin maybe it's
Merlin's book maybe it's a Ministry of
magic book or maybe it just means magic
I don't know
JP added to Instagram tend to stay away
from Twitter
they posted nothing on Discord what
I mean I guess they're just totally
I I am curious to why they just did it
on here I don't know if they're if
they're testing something with their
social media or what I have no idea
foreign
so in addition to the actually you know
what I haven't even checked a c
I don't think this has audio with it but
let me mute okay so I'm gonna mute our
stream music and okay the audio is set
to on for here
yeah nothing no music at all okay
somebody was over here asking
is it me or some videos muted yeah I
don't hear anything from this one so I
don't know if it's intended to be that
way
or not
but yeah
so oh you guys are scaring me for a
second saying no audio
don't you talk about the mic I'm like
what did I hit the switch okay so in
addition to the the little post here it
says an unauthorized guide to Hogwarts
there's more about this book though that
I want to talk about in a second okay so
let's go to the next one this one super
interesting
common room is full of secrets
character walks over to the glass which
Chandler told us not to tap the glass
now watch this though we're gonna pause
this one boom right here look at this
down here
all right this is where I need I need
the the combined power of chat here
to help figure this out
look at this down here
okay this one this first word I'm pretty
clear that's take take staircase
two
and then it looks like the start of a k
right here maybe
take staircase two
something
go down hallway
think maybe t-h-i-n
and then this right here to me looks
like band
let's see if we get any yeah we don't
really get any more when I let it play
let's let it play again though
all right so common room secrets
Hogwarts full of secrets the common
rooms are no exception tip number one
take staircase to something something
so then I I had to tweet out you know we
still have a lot of questions about
Hogwarts I can see gameplay of course
and we still have a lot of questions
about the story which I hope they don't
answer a lot of those I feel like the
story is better left
let us Discover it you know when we play
the game
I have zero doubts though that the
exploration is going to be top-notch and
I feel like this post I feel like these
are supposed to go together so they're
talking about this guide to Hogwarts and
then we go over and it starts showing us
tip number one
so I think these are going to be tips
that we find
I don't know if it's going to be other
students the question is who gives us
this book
who gives us the book is the question
can I make it bigger it's like it's
Instagram they don't make it easy let me
see if I can yeah even if I try Control
Plus to zoom in
so
I mean what could we do to make this
bigger
uh I could screenshot it here let's
screenshot it
we could screenshot it and then
oh my gosh come on dude
come on wait what
I want you to zoom in
all right did they do did they up did
Microsoft update this what in the world
okay there you go I mean so it's blurry
but
maybe that's a scroll of paper we saw in
the state of play that our character
pulls up I like the way you think djane
I like the way you think
yeah I think these are going to be
things that we get the book early in the
game from someone
and then we're going to collect these
tips throughout I don't know if they're
going to
maybe something is caught I almost see
it being kind of like our version of the
Marauders map even though it's not a map
but it's something that maybe they are
going to have a map component in there
we don't know yet
but we're giving it early in the game by
someone as like hey I know you're new
here
I know you're starting as a fifth year
you're probably going to need some stuff
only problem is
I lost the book last year and peeves
destroyed it and so the pages are
scattered something like that will
happen to where we have to kind of go
out and then find these Pages maybe we
get them from students or it could be
exactly like you said it could be
something that we see you know floating
around the castle and we have to get
them
so this one I think I don't know if this
I guess this is the tip right here
take staircase to something
go down the hallway
I don't know if this is barred or banned
but I think that's that's what that is
right there
common room secret so these are
specifically just for the common rooms
you guys
the attention to detail and everything
that they're going to be packing in here
is gonna be incredible
it's just gonna be incredible
even if like like I said we don't know
about the gameplay we don't know about
the Spells we don't know about all that
but I have the full confidence that
the exploration is going to be amazing
Tom you know what Tom
relax Tom
it it'll be okay
it's it's gonna be all right Tom
I I promise it'll be okay
will you read
n-o-m-i-s comment
take staircase to Kitchen go down
hallway third Barrel
does this refer to the barrel from
hufflepuff's video with the barrel
outside dude
that's a little bit that's a little bit
too on do you work for Avalanche
Nam is dead no Miss dad
that that feels too accurate to me
I think you I think you nailed it
I don't know how you got all of this
takes to I don't know how you got all of
this
unless this text is visible somewhere
else
take staircase to Kitchen go down
hallway
third Barrel
I'm gonna I want to see it again because
I feel like there was something before
the third Barrel
but even if there is I think you nailed
the gist of it yeah it feels like
there's room over here for another word
but
foreign yeah I was thinking maybe that's
think but third definitely works too
third Barrel yeah I think he nailed it
and we've already seen that as a spot
where somebody's kind of
searching around
in that spot and we can see one of those
little
pieces of paper there
so maybe this is the common room secret
tip number one for Hufflepuff
and that's where we go and find the page
so maybe when we find this it will fill
in what what whatever the tip is
[Music]
I think you nailed it though for sure
Neil Harrison and maybe I'd need some
context why is Poppy evil
it's just kind of a fandom joke
it started on expecto goes stream
Christy is Right evil poppy gives us the
book and teaches us Avada kada
all right all right Tom all right I got
you Tom I get why you're excited
you're you're forgiven
you're forgiven Tom
that was enough that was a
a solid enough comment to get excited
about
so all is good Tom yeah nama's Dad your
secret I mean Avalanche employee lock it
down turn them into Chandler wood right
now
Nam is Devo
that's that's it
they were like we have to change we have
to change just a little something
namas means Simon Simon backwards okay
I think the Outpost will be the
remaining page that we need to find all
right nama's Dad claiming they don't
work for Avalanche
I'm not sold
I'm not sold just yet
what did he say uh he basically just
filled this in take staircase to Kitchen
go down the hallway third Barrel
Tom is like
I need retro to see this comment I need
him to see it right now
we haven't even gotten to the other
Pages yet you guys well actually the
last one's not really that big a deal
but I do want to talk about this one
I do want to talk about this one
because right here
you can see uh some fish swimming in
here and so we already know Chandler had
the tease about Don't Tap The Glass
the fact that we see Fish I think it's
one of two things I think it's either
giant squid
or mermaids
for me I think giant squid would be
funnier
or maybe it changes each time I don't
know
so expect to go posted this on the
Instagram I must say nice touch showing
us what happens if we try to break the
window in the Slytherin common rooms
especially after chander Warden us I
don't think they did show
I don't think they did show and if you
watch what Chandler said to
uh let's see
yeah he writes back to expecto go did we
show you what happens when you tap the
glass yeah I don't think they did
I think they're trying they're they're
further kind of going down this Rabbit
Hole of like look you can walk over and
just buy a random spell at this glass
then something's gonna happen but it
cuts off before
uh
nama's dad diamonds what could it mean
oh my goodness
this is like uh Chandler's alt account
his burner account or something
yeah expect to go fishing for knowledge
like going a little reverse engineering
there
I'm gonna say you showed us what's there
uh but then uh Chandler did have a good
an interesting reply to Ben as well
so Ben so that's what the book was in
the Autodesk presentation
I know I haven't been keeping up with
every comment some of you may mention
the Autodesk I'll show you what Ben's
talking about here
Chandler you're just scratching the
surface plenty more secrets that this
book has to bestow including what it's
actually called
inspector goes like my money's on
Merlin's Merlin's book
all right so this comment from Ben right
here
I already got you guys I got you guys
right here
right here
this
is from the Autodesk session
and our character is standing in front
of what we're pretty sure is Professor
Weasley who is also the deputy
headmistress we're pretty sure about
tell us the name of the book Chandler
Merlin's Journal
did I say the Myrtle
is that the same book that has the wand
floating over it I I was wondering that
too I don't it doesn't look the same
because
I did want to pull that up too Jay Rossi
I did want to pull that up too let's see
uh Hogwarts Legacy
collector's edition
actually I might have to go to the
unboxing
let's go to the unboxing
Hogwarts Legacy collectors
reaction
unboxing
all right because he he definitely opens
it up to where he can see okay there it
is right there yes see it's a completely
different book
which is weird right
that's
a bit odd why wouldn't it be the book
see if he gives us
okay so there it is open
speed
in the middle of the book The Cover and
spine of the book
is the ancient Magic
a little bit of Hogwarts Legacy right
there wait what does he say here he said
something about
the book
it's the ancient magic logo there
ancient magic logo oh yeah he's talking
about the this right here
this mysterious figure it's very this
mysterious figure I remember him saying
that yeah
and so then that's the one right here
and then back to the Instagram post
whoops
that right there
now this also looks a lot like
back to the Autodesk here
it looks a lot like
which I mean it's just a Hogwarts crest
look at the symbol right there
Merlin's book versus morgana's book
[Music]
oh my goodness dude
I gotta pull out this segment right here
and send to James
discuss on the live stream tomorrow
oh man
maybe maybe
CW with the five dollar Super Chat yo CW
thank you so much dishes are done which
means time for bed
uh
appreciate you retro and to you as well
chat CW appreciate you my friend
appreciate you thank you so much for
showing love with the Super Chat and
always appreciate your support on the
stream hope you have a good night uh
yeah I need I need to do dishes as well
had to push that back to
start the live stream on time but oh man
dishes one of those just annoying
necessary things right but it does look
I mean the crest right there we also see
it in the other spot too
Christy Jean Dyer with another gifted
membership dude we might unlock two new
Emoji tonight let's go
hey Ray how's it going by the way I saw
your comment earlier Ray I appreciate
that glad you enjoyed the channel so
much
yeah I'm not sure DJing I do think
somebody was saying if you go back and
watch the Autodesk that it does look
like Professor Weasley gives you the
book
the reason that
that's what I I'll just be on it like
that was my first thought too
but then this throws me off right here
don't tell the Headmaster
consider this an unauthorized authorized
guide to Student Life
although
if the Headmaster is Professor Phineas
black as many of us are guessing
that would make sense because he's kind
of a jerk
he's kind of a jerk
so it could very well be a situation
where Weasley's like look
I know Professor Black's not gonna do
any extra to help this kid
so I gotta do something to help this kid
out
let me give them this book that we can't
say is like an official guide
dude and that would make sense coming
from the Weasley family too they're like
such a
historic Wizarding family
so maybe it's something that another
Weasley has
started working on in their time at
Hogwarts but clearly I I mean I think in
terms of gameplay I think this is going
to be our this is gonna be everything
this is going to be our log book this is
where we're gonna track quests this is
where we're going to all those tips and
um like secrets that we were talking
about
missions I think all that's going to be
found right here I could see us tracking
magical creatures with this
very exciting very exciting now we
didn't get to the last one yet but the
last one
is pretty much just a scene that we've
already seen before
yeah I think so too Logan
re-watch in the Autodesk scene
J Rossi if it is Merlin's book maybe it
is found in that cave area with the
pensive by the statue
two important books Helen Chandler I
know right so it's like we got the book
for the
collector's edition and then we have
this book
yeah it's definitely for sure a
different book
Shadow guide it says my bet is that
tapping the glass summons died late from
the zoo summons him not only from the
zoo but from the future
summons him all the way from the future
yeah new story yeah you just said it
could be our journal or book I think
it's going to be that and then also a
way to like
give us hints and tips and for us to
just keep track
of things along the way I think so
yep I think you're right too Logan like
about specifically about the common room
because it says common room secrets but
I feel like this will just be one
section
I feel like the common room secrets is
just one little piece of the overall
book
Amore poet why is some everyone so
obsessed with Merlin
because they expect they'll go
why
no it's just one of those things that I
think the fandom has loved to grab hold
of you know and just run with it
I'm trying to think of something that
would be comparable back in the days of
hair the hairy early days of the Harry
Potter fan and before we had books five
six and seven
there was a lot of shipping so I kind of
see it as like the old Shipping Wars
when people would ship different
characters
and then kind of one of the jokes I
always shouldn't say joke but I would
say a small bit of the fandom believed
that Harry was going to be a horcrux but
a lot of people were like no way that's
ridiculous
and now it actually ended up being being
true
foreign
yeah Christy yeah he spins the the globe
there as he walks by
interacting with the item
can it it only makes sense in the
context of that we're starting as a
fifth year in fact I think it makes even
more sense because
I think our character is
I don't know if I'm gonna say totally
new to The Wizarding World but I think
our character knows very little of the
Wizarding World
so they're gonna need a lot of extra
help to get caught up so it makes even
more sense for them to have this kind of
special guide like look we know you're
throw we're throwing into fifth year
classes but
here's something to kind of help you
along
the book is just the main menu
an unauthorized guide to Hogwarts
I mean hey though we haven't seen the
main menu yet so that would be it that
would be a fun reveal
okay let's Zara that'd be a fun reveal
oh let's see here
maybe it's what influenced the Marauders
map they may have even influenced the
name Marauders
you know I thought I
something similar to that to JP and it
went back to something that
Troy Levitt said on an interview with
podcast now how he talked about
he thought there could be some things in
this game
that people will that will kind of
become Canon or people will like them so
much that they we consider them like
head cannons like being like Oh that's
that's how it really happened or maybe
they'll even adopt that in in future
stories that are movies books whatever
kind of Harry Potter things we get in
the future
drawing faces is hard yeah I'm terrible
at drawing the folio Brew tie exactly
Shadow guided
what book did Lupine give us
ah you talking about like the spell book
like that they used in Harry's third
year
just want to know how much is the
Nintendo switch
uh I'd say it'll be
what 59 I'd say it'll be I think it's
already available for pre-order at 59.99
we just don't know the release date for
it yet
for sure Jay Rossi even if it's not in
the book that's a good point there will
definitely be a way to track
I think so
two things that are hugely popular that
bore you dark arts and Merlin Morgana
well I mean to be fair
the dark arts that is kind of being
brought about by Avalanche I mean
Avalanche was definitely pushing that
the Merlin stuff not so much the Merlin
stuff is largely fandom driven I think
although I mean they they mentioned him
by name and his name appears in the
background in the
Gameplay trailer but other than that
yeah they haven't really done that much
to kind of push the whole Merlin stuff
want to make a horcrux yikes Shadow
guided jeez I don't think I don't think
that will happen but
Jordan do I think it will control all on
PC yeah I don't see why not yeah
I mean they'll definitely have
controller
options available and then mouse and
keyboard yeah I mean I think it'll be
almost might make it even easier really
with being able to aim with mouse
all the potion book he gets in Half
Blood Prince yeah that was Snape's
potion book
yep no no released date yet no release
date for switch
oh you guys are talking about Loki I've
seen Loki Loki's awesome Kieran I think
of the Knights of the Round Table in
King Arthur when I hear Merlin not
Hogwarts in Harry Potter
yeah I mean it's definitely a different
version of Merlin in the Harry Potter
world because it wouldn't have even made
sense for him to be
it wouldn't have even made sense
timeline wise for him to be a student at
Hogwarts but that
it's just something she borrowed from
you know our lore I mean that's like
King Arthur Knights of the Round Table
that's
such an iconic
character and
wizard I mean Merlin may be the most
iconic wizard
trying to think
I mean Merle is honestly like these days
the past I don't know 100 years or so
Gandalf probably and then Harry Potter
more recent times but like going way
back I mean Merlin has just been a
character throughout
many many years of History so I think
it's kind of a fun little nod that she
brought into Harry Potter
but it's not like that exact version of
Merlin you know that we think about
I mean it Merlin could be nothing more
in this game than the puzzles honestly
hope James is not here to hear me say
that
but I mean we we know Merlin is at least
in the game that much though
[Music]
Red Dead red kind of reminding you of
the Red Dead Redemption 2 Journal yeah
yeah
actually part of English History as we
have few records from that time
la Jay Rossi loved the Arthurian Legends
Merlin could just be a last name right
it's just some random dude with Merlin
no but I mean if you think about in the
entire Wizarding World they base their
um I guess what would be a good
comparison for the order of Merlin
at first I was thinking Purple Heart
like in our modern world but it's not
really so much a Purple Heart it's
really like
I don't know let's look that up
see what the HP lexicon has on it what
is order of Merlin
uh let's see if okay HP Lex con has an
entry
yeah so I mean it kind of is maybe it's
more like Nobel Prize
order of Merlin is an honorific given to
witches and wizards for their service to
The Wizarding Community although we now
think of the order of Merlin as an award
it was originally conceived by Merlin
himself as an organization which made
rules against using Magic on Muggles
that that almost leans even more into uh
how Merlin could you know be involved in
the story for Hogwarts Legacy order of
Merlin is awarded in one of three levels
first class is the most prestigious
given for acts of outstanding bravery or
distinction and carries a green ribbon
second class has a purple ribbon and is
awarded for achievement or Endeavor
beyond the ordinary third class is for
those who have made a contribution to
our store of knowledge or entertainment
and as a white ribbon
order of Merlin
third class
gilderoy Lockhart
[Music]
I'm pretty sure Lockhart was uh
third class
oh yeah so here we go here are the
holders of it
Damocles belby Arcturus black
whoa what did Arcturus black get one for
do we know
it is uh unclear if this is the
grandfather who was awarded the order of
Merlin first class for services to the
ministry
but we're not sure if this is the right
one
Albus Dumbledore Cornelius fudge
Lockhart Lupine McGonagall orabella
Nutley
Pita Pettigrew wait what
what the heck
[Music]
oh
dude he was posthumously awarded order
of Merlin when Sirius got sent to
Azkaban oh
so I'm sure they revoked that
oh my gosh
[Music]
let's all write to the ministry
get me an order of Merlin
a phantom draws have a good night thanks
for stopping by
[Music]
oh Bradley that's a good question do we
think there will be Muggles in the game
muggle interaction
I mean I want to say no I mean I want to
say yes but
we definitely haven't seen any evidence
that there will be
because it looks like the area that
we're kind of roaming outside Hogwarts I
think those were all witches and wizards
right like all those little vendors that
we were walking up to
man and now I'm kind of I'm curious
about this Tilly toke Newt scamander are
the only other two that we have written
down
very cool very cool what is this
Damocles Bell B let's see what he got
the receive the order of Merlin oh he
was the one who invented the wolf Spain
potion hey now that's a that's
definitely
a good reason
for getting the award a favorite student
of Horus Slughorn received
I knew I recognized the name Marcus
belby
yo Noob 9227 with the Super Chat
Noob thank you so much for the Super
Chat
just a friendly reminder to stay
hydrated man you guys are so awesome the
super chat's half the time they don't
even have questions they're just they're
just like shouting out the the channel
tell me how much they enjoy the channel
reminder to stay hydrated tonight we
have black cherry Waterloo is tonight's
beverage of choice
and this one is actually almost empty
by far my favorite flavored Waters I've
tried Lacroix and I've tried
there's another one called bubbly and
then I feel like there's one more that
we've tried
a lot of them leave kind of this bad
aftertaste Waterloo though top of my
list so far
not sponsored by the way
thank you so much new very much
appreciate your support
okay
you guys are starting the petition for
uh
to get me an order of Merlin let's go
if you like sparkling water have to try
Sparkling Ice
so wait do you just is this something
you make on your own I mean I'm sure you
can make it on your own but
Waterloo water from the loop
oh do you guys have this in the UK it
might not go over well
might not go over well over there as
much
[Music]
would love to see me look at it live
wait look at what live
[Music]
you can find it on Amazon oh wait so
that's a brand so the Sparkling Ice is a
brand
oh Daigle said okay scroll up
retro check out this data play video at
8 12 they show you talents and abilities
they look like cars but below them it's
an open book right yeah yeah I'm pretty
sure I remember that
so let's see
Hogwarts Legacy Gameplay trailer
a 12
.
oh yes behind it
yes yes yes
that's a good call so yeah that could be
that could definitely be the book that
Chandler is showing off and uh teasing
on the
on the Instagram page good catch I
completely forgotten about that
it's right here at 8 12 guys right there
let's see if they show it again because
we get another
it's not that now this right here that
is what somebody was talking about
earlier maybe that
oh
there it was
there it is
there's the book right there
literally right in the character's hands
it's right there
we found it Chandler we found it
oh my gosh that's
of course we saw that at the time of
course we did
but it just like just sinking in now
yeah it's got to be the same book right
here
so here they are they find the little
Page hit collect boom right into the
book
so that is 100 the book that they just
showed on the Instagram page that's the
book that's going to track the tips now
now though I want to go back to
exactly you gotta find the pages
book of spells confirmed I think I think
that's just one of the things that are
going in there though yeah yeah
oh man I'm scrolling back up yeah you
guys are all freaking out too
it's like Derek there it is
right there
so we were right here at 8 12 so at
eight uh if you want to go back and
watch it again yourself it's at 8 17.
collect right into the book you know
what I'm gonna screenshot that right now
right
oh
they cut away quick though
let's screenshot that
I don't know why that half the time that
doesn't work there we go I just
screenshotted the whole thing
yeah whoever said that
you nailed it because I think what they
were actually originally talking about
though
is there's another scene
oh gosh they're all we've gotten so many
trailers now so many bits of information
that
let me speed this up it's all running in
my head I think it's in this trailer
though too
where there's a moment where
they're like out in the
they're inside Hogwarts and there's one
it's kind of up above them
another one of those floating pages
oh dude okay wait
I think she just had the reg a regular
book in front of her probably just her
book for charms class okay yeah
I think that's all that one is
Professor Weasley could give us the book
taking us a Daigle nice thank you Daigle
yeah Marauder's manual
I'm trying to get to that spot where
when I first or wait Amore poet said
when I first saw the book
they show in the Autodesk presentation
my first thought was a book you're
seeing in the trailer right now thought
they were the Same Book for a while now
yeah yeah so I think they're all
it's definitely I think they're all
connected for sure
you guys remember which other one I'm
talking about
there's another scene oh hey there was a
book out right there but that's probably
their potion our character's potion
right here on the right side
where is that other scene
it's in this trailer okay good yeah
I was thinking it was definitely in this
one
I'm trying to skim down here too
I feel like it is
I feel like it's coming up right after
oh there it is there it is there it is
there it is
and we
okay the book here looks
definitely looks different though
the book definitely looks different
right here
okay so we're just going frame by frame
here
all right so
we get the little flying page right here
which is a little bit different than the
other page that we just saw
that one was like a there was a collect
prompt
remember that it was collect this one
they do the spell
accio
which maybe I mean this is edited so
they could have taken out certain
prompts we don't know and then there we
briefly see
that's a completely different book
but I gotta think it's the same one
books book skins right like maybe you
can customize the
or maybe they changed no no I wouldn't
have changed it because
of the I mean all the way back here even
in the Autodesk
maybe the clip has a book placeholder
and it should be the Hogwarts book
that could that's kind of what I was
about to say but then I remember this
which they've had
maybe they just didn't I don't know
or I like somebody's idea about the
Skins too maybe you could uh
oh you think he echoed the whole book
let's see hold on sorry I'm playing it
as smaller
ah that doesn't look like the whole book
to me
I don't know maybe
no that that just looks like a
because it's the same color on both
I don't see that sort of shade of
let's see am I watching at the highest
quality too
no let's Crank It Up to 4K
oh yeah a little bit a little bit
sharper yeah that that to me just looks
like a
although
then right there it kind of does look
like a but it looks like a different
color it looks Brown
his hand is empty beforehand well it was
emptying the other shot too he he like
after he picks up that parchment
remember then he pulls out the book puts
it in so I think let's see we can't
really see
now watch now that I I lean more toward
I I think you guys are right
it does look like the book just goes
instantly into his hand with this one
right
there so yeah we can't see the other
side but
it does
like right there it does not look like a
full a full book
but then right here
that's pretty that's a pretty thick book
right there
probably another book
that's another thought there could be
multiple books that we're collecting
Pages for that's a thought
that's the Charms book
Dr sherbet or a quest book book covers
would be cool now see okay now that we
watch that though let's go back to the
other one and watch it again
let's watch the animation here
okay so we're gonna go frame by frame
see like how so see they're not holding
the book
they're not holding the book right there
there's the prompt Square for collect
presumably they hit Square to collect he
immediately pulls out the book
opens it up
and it just goes right in
then he closes the book
foreign
that's tough
I think the other one could be it could
be they're summoning a complete book
or man it would have been this would
have been so perfect if when he held it
up it was the same cover
then we would know
but the cover is throwing me off because
that one that one right there
definitely looks like the Hogwarts book
the log book The Quest book whatever
we're calling it look at it look at it
right there when he when he kind of
turns it
foreign
[Music]
all kinds of love for the stream tonight
Noob thank you so much different book
covers for different types of tips
you know what else I thought at first
Noob I thought what if it's because we
know it talked about
common room secrets
so I thought maybe the book takes on a
different appearance depending on the
house you're in
however
because this one looks
reddish or brown which makes me think
it's that one right there for sure
but then this one back here
I was thinking maybe that one was like
oh the Ravenclaw book or something but
our characters in Gryffindor for this
whole trailer
also love the vids keep up the amazing
work thank you so much Noob thank you
for the love and support
on the channel okay it's right here
after Nick
and I know I've made the window small
again sorry oh no it's not after Nick
it's after
right there okay
[Music]
the animation it could be either or I
cannot tell if that's
like right there that does not look like
a whole book
it just doesn't it looks like a single
page
and then when they summon it in so he
could be like drawing the book out right
there just like he did in the other shot
and we can't see it
and then let's see how he puts it away
holding it in the left hand
kind of turns it a little bit and then
goes to tuck it away
all right so back to 8 18 here
all right I'm gonna put it in instead of
fast let's slow this down
so collect holding into the left hand
opens the book goes in
oh that's like the I think that's the
exact same animation we're just seeing
it from the other side
Levi maybe it's a student's book we have
to find for the bulletin board that like
when I first saw that other scene that's
what I thought I thought these were like
the bulletin board things that's a
possibility too I was just hoping that
it would all be the same book and then
we could be like
and we could point to all these uh
multiple spots in the trailer where
we've seen this
but I think they're one this one right
here I think 100 percent
matches that book that we just talked
about that's from the Instagram post
I think that one is for sure the same
book
[Music]
oh my gosh that looks
oh dude
it looks so strange when you slow it all
down like this the effects look so good
[Music]
oh I didn't want to have the sound on
all right let's catch up on some
comments here
high IQ Warrior I think the notes quests
are one of the catch-up Quests for the
player since they start late
Adventure book Ryan says books you have
to collect that you have to find pages
to that book say a Charms book of spells
volume one yeah for sure you could
definitely have multiple books that
could be a mechanic that we use
throughout and maybe the so maybe the
pages oh that was I knew there was
another thing
I knew there was another thing
Hufflepuff common room
hey my video shows up in the search nice
okay so this is the one
there's a scene in this trailer
we'll just let it play through because I
love watching these they're so good
they're all so good man I thought about
starting to do the tier list tonight but
I don't think we're gonna have enough
time
yeah I don't think we're gonna have time
maybe we'll see we'll see how things go
yeah it's coming up right here
Sherman 4k on this one yeah we are right
there
I think that is definitely another one
of the pages
for the book
the book
we don't know the name yet so we shall
just call it the book
maybe it's just ancient Magic Book
we know the collector's edition was
called floating floating ancient magic
wand with book
who knows
but yeah so that I think that's
definitely a page in it
right before you get to the Hufflepuff
common room
[Music]
here we'll watch it in slow-mo and even
have the character standing over there
looking there it is right there you
start to see it
now that one could also have something
with how you unlock how you enter the
Hufflepuff common room because we know
it's a specific barrel and you have to
tap it in a certain way
but that to me looks just like another
one of those bits of parchment that
we're seeing
[Music]
yeah the one the Hogwarts one is
definitely more of a brown that one
looks blue bluish kind of a bluish green
and gold
High accuwear I think the notes quests
are one of the catch-up quests since
they start late yeah I think so too I
think it's a way to kind of help our
character
figure out the world but also a good
like game mechanic to help us as a
player get introduced to the world
books you have to collect then you have
to find the page oh yeah I think I read
that one Ryan by the way don't know if
y'all figured it out yet but the script
at the bottom of the common room secrets
video tells the directions to the
Hufflepuff common room
it's the directions to that exact piece
of parchment we just looked at
[Music]
yeah somebody popped in here earlier and
had it exactly
I said that's I think you nailed it
that's it do you work at Avalanche
I wonder if this will be a be like
Pokemon Arceus like we are making
Hogwarts A History or whatever oh
maybe we're like the grand wait when was
the bathilda bag shot born we wouldn't
be her grandson
I think Matilda bag shot was
I don't want to take the trailer away so
I'll look it up on my phone here
bathilda bag shot
birth
oh my gosh I'm terrible at typing on a
phone
can type on a computer really well on a
phone not so much
all right but filled a bag shot
already an adult meaning she was at
least this makes
1873 befilda's latest date of birth wait
is that correct
she was born before 1881.
for sure so for sure she was before
1881.
they're saying 1873
Harry Potter Phantoms saying 1873
okay so here's why they think this
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
chapter 11.
when the Dumbledore family moved to
godrick's Hollow in 1890
wait a second
that's when they first moved to godrics
Hollow
was 1890
[Music]
I don't know guys 1890 that that's a
significant date for some reason
okay
that's crazy though that so Hogwarts
Legacy starts
when the Dumbledore family first moved
to godrics Hollow
okay so when the Dumbledore family moved
to godrick's Hollow in 1890 after
percival's arrest bathilda was already
an adult
and came by to welcome them
meaning she was at least 17 years of age
okay so no chance of seeing her in
Hogwarts
unless like foreign
this makes 1873 bathilda's latest date
of birth
so if she was born in 1873 that means
she started Hogwarts in 1884.
so
would she be a seventh year
in 1890 then
hmm
perhaps we are assisting
oh
dude do we know bathilda's house
what if she's the Ravenclaw companion
wait she lived in godrick's Hollow
surely she I mean I don't guess you had
to be a griffin or to live in godric
Solo but
let me see let me see let me see do we
know bathilda's house
build a bag shot house
of course it's pulling up Matilda
bagshot's home what house has bathilda
back shot in
ah I would think Gryffindor but dude
what if she was the Ravenclaw companion
okay I'm off the deep end now I'm off
the deep end I know I know
all right let's get caught up let's get
caught up now
see you guys reacting to my my rambling
Matilda was around Dumbledore's age so
it gets a little bit older than
Dumbledore
because he would have been
yeah he's not he's not started school
yet when we're going in Hogwarts
right Tom hey welcome Tom thanks for
being here I know that was a funny shot
too seeing the
that's tip one that they're referring to
third Barrel yep yep exactly
student just staring at the pages right
books just appear and disappear when
needed like your wand in Ravenclaw
common room the one Pops in the hand as
needed for gameplay right yeah
in the 8 12 Mark what is the book on the
ability card labeled core
[Music]
what is the ability card
[Music]
what is the book on the ability oh this
book right here
yeah I don't know
I don't know that's a good question too
though maybe it's just maybe it's this
exact book
we will use the book and see it every
time we open any of the categories they
show at 8 14. character inventory
talents collection challenges map
Outpost settings stable says
[Music]
so
I wonder what that was that we pick up
then well and and tips too we know it's
gonna be it's somehow related to the
little tips and secrets that we're gonna
find about the common rooms too
Thomas I just appreciate we could sit
here for hours to talk about a game like
this finally right
I know dude it's exciting
yeah exactly yep isn't that significant
yeah the 1890 indeed
[Music]
so the main character is Dumbledore
what
[Music]
oh my gosh
yeah they've been trolling us all this
time you're you don't get to choose your
own character you're actually playing as
young Dumbledore
hoping we could swim have underwater
combat travel and explore the whole map
why not the lake
Dr sherbet have to call it here 3 A.M oh
yeah that is really late hey thanks for
hanging out thanks for helping us learn
how to pronounce sherbet as well
sherbet lemon
uh Britain kitten plus it's possible
there are creatures in the Black Lake
that aren't there during Harry's time
indeed
she's trying to become Dumbledore's
friend if bathilda was born in 1873 that
that's what I'm thinking
now that's so close
and to be fair this is the HP Wiki and
listen to the way that they're stating
this too
because it's not
they're guesstimating here based on this
comment so here's what it says again
with the Dumbledore family moved to
godrick's Hollow in 1899 this is from
chapter 11 of Deathly Hallows the bribe
I might have to go reread this just to
see Matilda was already an adult and
came by to welcome them
see like that like how do you know
I can't remember how much they talk
about her appearance and even I mean
appearances can be deceiving people can
look way older way younger than they
actually are so
I'm not as exciting as that would be to
have bathilda in the game as someone we
recognize as a seventh year possible
Ravenclaw companion
I don't think it's I don't think it's a
given
that 1873 is the absolute latest date
because of the way they're wording it
here
she was already an adult
like did it say she was an adult unless
it explicitly said she was an adult
1873 her latest date of birth and then I
guess also like when she was born in
1873
that could affect
like if she was born in
I don't know how birthdays work with
Hogwarts and what is hogwarts's cut off
date
is it the school start date
now see right here in that shot we don't
see any
there's no book
go back again
dude watch this part right here again
are they hiding something from us right
here
I think they are I think our character
is holding something out
to collect
now we kind of see it in that other shot
oh wait let's see right here do they
show anything there
now we're going to be going back through
every scene like looking for books
all right all right all right
Dumbledore would join Hogwarts in the
player seventh year correct Noob correct
yeah
so she'd be a sixth year in 1890.
yeah Macy yeah that's where my mind went
to [ __ ] is she the Ravenclaw companion
dude we would lose our mind
if bathilda
is the Ravenclaw companion
no no no Kieran we don't know her house
from what I could find I I think the
assumption would be Gryffindor because
she lived in God it's Hollow but
I don't think it's a get I mean just
because you were born somewhere I don't
think that means you would have to be
in that house Ryan thank you for subbing
to the channel
foreign
have a good one
build a textbook that is foundational in
the knowledge of Hogwarts right
you just you assist bethilda in the
early days of
creating
Hogwarts A History
oh that would be so epic though if we
meet her early in the game and dude it
would
it would honestly fit so well for a
Ravenclaw to be the one who's writing
about the history of the school would it
not
she's she's probably already working on
it as a seventh year or sixth year
whatever however the math works out
exactly
there's a good chance she could be at
the school but again because I was what
I was saying I I seriously may have to
reread that and Deathly Hallows if any
of you have that handy
look look glance over chapter 11 and see
if you could find
what makes them I mean adults that's so
people like I said people look older or
younger than they are all the time
1873 birth means she would have attended
1884 to 1890.
she'd be a seventh year when we arrived
like yeah if it's 1873
yeah
didn't she consider Dumbledore to be a
younger brat or something or am I
thinking of fan fiction Dumbledore DLC
I think it'd be epic if we get to the
third like if they make a Trilogy and
the third game is
I don't know man I don't know how they
would
how exactly it would work but if they
made it that far then you have I mean
you have to do Dumbledore at that point
you have to
you have to
Pages could be like skill points for a
specific skill tree you can see all of
what I wrote at the top of the screen
I'm not sure we're talking about Diego
it's probably maybe it's moved past now
it might have been
maybe they were talking about right here
or you might have just been talking
about scrolling back up
her first year would be 18. we're we're
all like trying to do the math now
okay if she was born in February
she was born in December of 1873.
no no Albus is definitely not the main
character
they know that she was an adult because
of the interview that she did with Rita
Skeeter while she was writing the life
and lies of Albus Dumbledore
interesting okay
70 right right yeah 17 in The Wizarding
World
is considered adult right
Paige on those stairs wait what where no
I was talking to you guys
all right so it's probably back in
this shot Maybe
or this shot here
[Music]
give me a rough uh I know you can't see
the time but
give me a rough time stamp
I'll let it play again right here or on
the spiral staircase another flapping
page
uh okay let's go back here this is where
we were we were right here
let me speed it up
okay that one we talked about that one
already
[Music]
I'm speeding it up right now so okay no
spiral staircase here
oh oh oh wait were you talking about
right there
oh I saw that little uh
window that little area of light shining
through right there
I thought that was it for a second
[Music]
maybe the book at 1406 all right we'll
check that here next
I don't even remember what else we were
going to talk about tonight I had
something else in the title
maybe we've covered it maybe we haven't
I don't remember
but this is too good too good going down
the rabbit hole on this book
the ancient Magic Book
all right back outside now
oh oh okay wait there's a staircase I
don't see one there okay now we're
talking about companions
outside now you said spiral staircase so
definitely think if we were inside
foreign
peeves
[Music]
oh right here probably
whoa what is this okay that's the stair
moving right there
[Music]
there yes
oh
let's go forward one more frame
two more for there it is
right here
top left
top left
uh Ryan was asking about more than one
year yeah I'm I'm fairly confident it's
just one year but it's not confirmed
not confirmed so
[Music]
right we're we're in a we're going down
a deep Rabbit Hole now
foreign
it would totally fit if it was a
Ravenclaw who was
who was the one who writes
Hogwarts of History
putting her bets on it now wait hold on
what's Jay talking about something for a
side quest
I see you comment Jay about that'd be
great for a side quest
if not wasted potential
at the very least jairasi says students
who have August birthdays would need to
receive their letters prior to their
birthdays as the cutoff date for
confirming their places is July the 31st
you're a wizard Harry hey Porter Thomas
welcome thank you for subscribing to the
channel here
they would also need time to get
supplies right right you're a wizard
Harry yeah we don't know for sure Ryan
spin faster as well thank you for
subbing to the channel
foreign
of Grindelwald
Noob are you talking about somebody else
maybe the book of 1406 yeah yeah I need
to check that here in a second
hey Christy thanks so much for all the
love and support tonight
for sure stay safe anyone down in
Florida
make sure you guys are safe if you need
to get away get away
get away
Hogwarts Legacy game play soon I mean
that's what Chandler's teasing and
pretty much said before the end of the
year so I mean minimum we've got three
months three months or less
maybe Game Awards
or if there's another big Sony event
that's what my money would be on
another big Sony event or possibly Game
Awards
well that guy turned him into stone I
think it was a uh
petrificus totalus Maybe
common Room videos lots of flying books
in those videos following students
wubby do I think the February date is
final or will it be delayed more
I feel pretty good about the February
date
I do
there's all I mean there's always a
chance that's just how game development
is you know there's always a chance
something could go wrong or
they can eat a little bit more time but
I I feel good about February I never
felt good about
November December 2022 never felt good
about that one but February I I feel
like that's a that's a pretty solid
Target
but until until you have the game in
your hands then
it's not official not official
Matilda is related to Grindelwald oh my
gosh dude
she actually supported her nephew's
views
now that I don't remember
oh you're gonna have some flooding
little fear yikes that's no fun either
that flooding can be really bad too
you think we'll be able to talk to the
portraits like to glean clues or for
quests or Secrets I like that idea
I like that idea
I feel like there's got to be at least
even if it's just a one-time story
moment I feel like we have to go to the
headmaster's office at least once right
at least once
so there's there's 100 you're gonna be
able to hear some of the talking
portraits in here there that would just
be a missed opportunity if not
big big missed opportunity if they don't
oh they're talking about that stone yeah
yeah Amore poet Amore poets right yeah
if you're talking about the stone where
the character drinks the potion yeah
then there's another one where it's
right when they're in the middle of that
section
well I was just watching earlier I was
like oh that looks so different when
you're watching it in
[Music]
it's right here
I think this one's like yeah see there
it is square
I don't think I've ever
been so many I've been trying to figure
out the spell casting for this game so
many times
I don't think I've ever caught that
right there or I I have and I've just
completely forgotten about it
Square for petrificus totalus
it's like a stealth attack
boom right there Then Square to interact
what
I thought this is what you were talking
about by the stone because watch this
I mean he he freezes but then he gets
like this look at that dude he gets like
this stone look
and then just fall straight down
then you got the option to interact or
are you gonna just like loot them or
something
then you're not supposed to be able to
use accio on oh wait but then it pops up
loot
so wait there's a difference between
Loot and interact I guess
you're not supposed to be able to use
accio on living things so
maybe it's car paper attract them but it
looks a lot like accio
portrait secret passwords and passages
some PS5 talk
Ray you still looking for one
they've been getting a lot more I saw
one day where they were pretty much up
all day on Playstation Direct
which is the first time I've seen that
where pretty much throughout the day you
could you could get one off of oh yeah
right there then there's that moment too
where they drink the potion turned to
stone
right Noob yeah trying to get into the
headmaster's office
sneaking in
oh yeah people are for sure gonna be
trying to do that
like Assassin's Creed assassinations
yeah it's
now now it makes me wonder like will we
also be able to cast petrificus totalus
from afar or is that only a stealth
spell
s look really good they do
right yeah I was thinking loot at first
but then they show a different prompt
for loot
maybe you could maybe interact as
I don't know I was thinking maybe you
take
the petrificus totalus off
[Music]
man it just looks so good running on
this fort like playing it at 4K as well
Leva Corpus is the spell
well Leva Corpus wasn't uh invented yet
that was a Snape spell now there are
similar spells like it
what happens now unafraid of detention
I'm gonna try it I'm gonna go back to
that shot and see if we can hear what
they say
let's see it's right this scene here all
right let me turn off our other music
so we can all hear this nice and clear
okay hopefully it's not too loud
just go right right about here raise
your spells plants and potions to
increase their power decide which I
don't think there's any game audio right
now
talents best fits your playstyle to
allow you to focus on your favorite
stuff there's not no game audio at all
in that part
unfortunately
unfortunately no game audio there so we
can't hear the spell
oh what have the two of you done
[Music]
be cool to have a Harry Potter watch day
with retro expect to go snow the weekend
before the game drops oh my gosh Daigle
that would be awesome I love that idea
I'm trying to get through
I at first I said all the games before
Hogwarts Legacy releases and I said that
a while ago but
we did finish uh Prisoner of Azkaban
so if you guys haven't checked that out
it is on the channel Majestic Omen
coming in with a 9.99 Super Chat
Majestic Omen thank you so much for
showing love to the stream loving the
late night live streams great finish to
the day hey that's good to hear Majestic
Omen that some people some people like
the late night
most the time when I talk about the
stream or post when I'm going live I get
a lot of comments from our UK friends
just like uh
I can never watch your live streams I'm
sorry I'm sorry
it's the only it's literally like the
only times I have right now available
anytime I ever I do take every now and
then I'll take a day off
and like this Friday I'm gonna be off I
don't even wanna every time I'm off a
day like that though during the week I
want to stream
I think it'd be fun to do like a
gameplay stream during the day but
inevitably something happens every time
every time I'm planning to do one
something happens
so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna commit to
it yet but keep an eye on the Twitter
keep an eye on the
YouTube Community page I actually forgot
to post I was even going live on there
tonight whoops
uh but I there could be a gameplay
stream on Friday but again every time I
try to do it something goes wrong so
don't count on it but I do want to do
more streams I really do right now it's
just almost impossible
with uh my schedule being the way it is
and having two kids you know it's just
it's not easy so this is like my only
window and I'm only committing to dude
there's another flying book there's
another
actually there are multiple
these look different though
look at that right there
hold on can you can you guys see that oh
yeah you can I was hoping my little uh
camera overlay wasn't cutting it off
right there yeah there's one right here
and then there's another one here now
these these feel different to me then
there's another one right there
now these do look
like a large like an actual book
oh
so many things I'm still noticing but uh
thank you so much majesticomen very much
appreciated
Charles says still betting that the
Spells are able to be on the four right
buttons then when you use right and left
trigger
to all
for eight more combinations
o to alt maybe meant to say alter
also shouldn't be able to cast crucio to
each other I know right
in that in that way exactly
[Music]
squares for interaction you can see in
the new clip right right right yeah yeah
you can see it all so yeah when you're
walking by in the common room trailers
yep
is there anyway uh anywhere I can go to
get updates about when ps5s are
available to buy Britain yes
if you have Twitter or even if you don't
have Twitter
there are a couple of really good
accounts to follow
um
oh what is the guy's name
I think it's Jake
Randall
Jake is awesome Jake has like built his
YouTube channel on
helping people get ps5s
and
not as much lately but like let me
scroll through like like today he was
helping people uh
pre-order the new God of War controller
uh the new oh my gosh that OLED switch
is gonna sell out like crazy
that Pokemon switch
so kind of scrolling through here to see
if he has any
recently but he he does a pretty good
job of posting and then also Wario 64 on
Twitter
this account is insane I mean 1.1
million followers ridiculous I mean they
tweet out all kinds of deals and stuff
but
anytime there's a PlayStation available
oh my gosh what is the Samus figure a
hundred and eight dollars
it looks like an amiibo are you kidding
I mean it's definitely higher quality
than amiibo but the size
yeah but yeah they're I wouldn't say
they're readily available at this point
but they are definitely
definitely much in a much better place
than they were you can you can catch
them if you keep an eye out
don't know if you saw retro there's a
door
oh my gosh dude I hate it when the
comment when it jumps forward like that
I completely lost it
I was starting to read somebody's
comment about
okay I think I'm getting close now I
think I'm getting close to it again
foreign
[Music]
Division I don't know if you saw it
retro there's a door on the small
tree or on the wait
wait wait okay let me back up there's a
door on the tree small Towers
headmaster's office with stairs that
lead to this outside Hive veranda
are you talking about in
this trailer
[Music]
tell Jake I need a PS5
he doesn't buy them for people he just
uh
helps people see when they're in stock
things like that
what platform is best to stream Harry
Potter Hogwarts content really
considering trying closer to Legacy
launch
uh you mean like live streaming the game
because I'm trying to figure that out
myself too
I mean
it's tough to answer that honestly like
and it's gonna be different if you're I
don't know if you're just starting out
like for me I have such an I've built
such an audience here on YouTube
I've considered doing some twitch
streams again for just gameplay and such
[Music]
so like for me
I don't know because I'm still debating
it in my head
on whenever I do gameplay streams where
do I want to stream it
it's a tough question it really is
but if you're oh man
like for me it kind of makes more sense
to do YouTube I feel like
right now I may change tomorrow but
right now that's what I think
let me see if my wife can take my my dog
is whining here
I think she needs to go out
if not I will step away and take her out
but yeah best best uh I assume you're
talking like twitch versus YouTube
and not console or PC
just want to know what spell is using to
Magic up a whole Cottage like it's
nothing
yep there you go I showed the showed the
tweets there
I know that was ridiculously pricey for
the
the little Metroid figure Samus
raises a good point
if you're if you're trying to make earn
a little bit of money with subs and and
stuff
which I don't know maybe you're not if
you're just starting out you wouldn't be
you wouldn't be dealing with that
because you wouldn't have the
qualifications met yet
but yeah if you're if you're concerned
like long term I mean twitch still is
the go-to place to watch live gameplay
it is but that's
where it ends honestly it's kind of
where it ends right there
and the the landscape is is rapidly
changing YouTube is making more of a
commitment in that area
David hey welcome David how's it going
have to watch the whole thing tomorrow
miss the first two hours oh my gosh so
we've been going in over two hours now
shout out to the replay Squad anybody
watching the sun replay now thank you
thank you
oh the Hogwarts shot with the nifflers
take a look and zoom in at the
Headmasters Towers
okay Hogwarts shot nifflers
where are all the niflas
where are you nifflers
you would think I would remember
timing and everything better
oh I hate it when it jumps up like that
yeah I thought it was more toward the
end
there is okay
great wizard wait wait what shot before
the nifflers maybe or a different shot
of the nifflers
foreign
probably talking about a different
moment with the nifflers though
yeah the mandatory ad stuff that's
another thing JP that I think I think
that really hurts
creators just starting out I really do
[Music]
foreign
I gotta open the door so my dog can go
outside
foreign
thanks for hanging out
have a good one see you next time
favorite part of the trailer is the
niffler stealing the brush
it's um
I
I don't know dude I don't know I could
definitely tell you that
I tried twitch for like three years and
I mean I assume you if you're just doing
it for fun then do it wherever you want
right it doesn't matter
wherever you're most comfortable
wherever you think it would work best
for you
but if you're trying to build an
audience it's really tough to start on
Twitch really tough I streamed for like
three years to five people most of the
time so
now I don't think we'd have as many
people watching now like I don't even
know how many we have in it right now
but I don't think it would be as many if
I was just doing a gameplay stream on
YouTube but it would still be more than
if I was on Twitch I think but I don't
know that's why I've kind of thought
about
testing the waters and doing some of
both again but clearly with how well
this live stream goes each week it's
just like
it definitely makes sense for me to keep
doing this live stream here on YouTube
it would it wouldn't make sense
not to
uh Ryan where can you download everybody
wants to know after seeing me Play-Doh
so
the way that
I did it
I talk about this in the last stream
if you just go and Google silverlade
right here silver laid Harry Potter PC
these are the instructions
of a possible way to get the game
running
on your Windows 10 machine
do it at your own risk
research your own
the legality of downloading things like
this
but that's that is an article I came
across online
so there you go
silver laid
s-i-l-v-e-r-l-a-i-d-e Harry Potter
medium
[Music]
Britain gotta sleep classes tomorrow hey
thanks for stopping by good luck in your
classes tomorrow
enjoyed the chat can't wait to see a
video about the book stuff I know right
now we found all this extra stuff to
talk about too
Nathan I'm convinced the Hogwarts Legacy
Community and just potterheads in
general the nicest people out there hey
I think they're pretty awesome too
Nathan I do I I grew up really
in in the Harry Potter Phantom grew up
I'm uh I'm an OG when it comes to the
Harry Potter fandom
Jake had a an 18 hole golf tournament
walked six miles ooh that's a lot
that's a lot
Santiago uh yeah most of the time yeah
if you want to see me without a hat go
to the beginning of the last live stream
the last live stream there there are
several videos where I don't have a hat
but now it's just kind of like it's
become just part of the uniform
basically
so it's it's a branding thing at this
point gotta gotta have the the Retro hat
here
uh I have a West Highland Terrier Ray
named Luna is her name
Noob don't listen to me I barely passed
School in college
you went to college though
all right let's see
let's watch let's throw the dark arts
nope
dark arts Hogwarts Legacy
this one
foreign
hey Jason always good to see you thanks
for hanging out man have a good one
producer of asking about both cases both
chamber and goblet oh you're talking
about a favorite
[ __ ] huge creators like asthma gold have
been talking about how bad the ads have
gotten why would anyone wait through
eight ads just to watch the Stream
that was exactly my point it just like
for the bigger creators it's not as big
of a deal but it like it kills any
chance of a of a new Creator succeeding
because it's like if you don't you're
not gonna explore and click on a stream
of somebody you don't know now who who
knows dude YouTube could change this
because right now I'm pretty sure like
have any I don't think you guys will
ever see an ad
unless I there is a button in like the
Creator dashboard or whatever
where I can hit show ads sometimes I'll
hit it before I start the stream like
when I when we have the 10 minute
countdown going sometimes I'll hit one
there and then I'll usually hit one
right when we're when I've already ended
the Stream
and I last time I was like hey if you
guys want to support the stream you can
watch this brief ad if you want to head
out it's all good but it's it's entirely
manual it's entirely manual twitch is
not like that at all it's like it's it
forced like the ads are mandatory and
even if you're somebody brand new to the
platform
you can't just say like oh I feel like
you should have the option to say
like his switch isn't even they're not
even making any money off of somebody
who's streaming to like five viewers
they're not I mean that the ad the ads
on that are just so small I just I think
it's so interesting
anyway
that's a that's a good point Daigle it
really is
Twinkle Toes well I'll be streaming
Hogwarts Legacy the hour it drops
I'll do there was another book that was
a different book though that was the
skull book
on dude I wish Steve or who was it
Steven no it wasn't Steven it was
Twinkle Toes
I will be doing
some
I just don't I don't know yet I don't
know
I'm so torn between what to do
when Hogwarts Legacy comes out
Jimmy should be easy right
part of me wants to do a live stream
part of me does the other part of me
wants to do it as a full
let's play that's not live streamed
then the other part of me knows I'm
gonna have to really be
I mean I'm gonna have to play the game
in a way that
I can get
the secrets that I want to make videos
on
details that I want to make videos on
just there will be plenty of Hogwarts
Legacy content and I will definitely
stream it at some point for sure for
sure
what that will look like and when I'm
still trying to decide
and I mean honestly like all you guys if
the game was out you're not gonna be
here watching my stream
[Music]
you're not gonna be watching my stream
you're gonna be playing the game
and you're not even gonna have my stream
up while you're playing because you
don't want to get nobody wants to get
spoiled on anything you know
I don't blame you I don't want to get
spoiled either
72 hours early right yeah
the three days early yeah that's true
what I'm hoping
fingers crossed
I would love
to be able to get an early copy
that you know is something that is done
in games media for
the mainstream so the igns The Game
Stops I mean everybody knows they get
games early for review
this Hogwarts Legacy is by far the game
that I have covered the most extensively
so
I don't know if Avalanche and WB will do
something like that I have no idea if
they do
I would love to be in that group that
gets an early copy Tater thank you so
much for the Super Chat 4.99 Super Chat
your first playthrough should be
intimate don't stream it see that's what
that's what a lot of people say right
that's what a lot of people feel like
now if I were to get the game early
I have no idea how early it would be
but that would help alleviate that
problem because obviously if I got it
early I'm not going to be able to stream
it but I could record it I could record
it all
and so the idea the recent companies do
this is because then the day the game
launches everybody has their reviews
ready to go so they're embargoed for a
certain period of time
Twinkle Toes says I'll be on vacation so
I'll be watching streams ah nice okay so
that would be the best of both worlds if
I got it early then I could have a bunch
of content already made before the game
comes out I could have a full-on play
through
if they give us like I don't know a week
or something
I could hopefully have at least kind of
a bare bones playthrough not doing
everything that would be I could do a
pre-recording of all that
then the game comes out
I could live stream it
but then part of me also wants to wait
to like give people time
to play it
oh
I I don't know I'm gonna be doing a lot
of it though
I'm gonna be doing a lot I mean you're
gonna see you guys will be sick of the
Hogwarts Legacy content it's just gonna
be it's gonna be crazy it's gonna be
everywhere
it's gonna be everywhere
Noob says I will have up your stream on
my second monitor so I can witness your
reactions but see what if I get ahead of
you though then you don't want it you
wouldn't want to know
you wouldn't want to see it yet
make a let's play first and then play it
live in a house chosen by subscribers I
like it Lee I like it a house Chosen and
then I mean I definitely plan multiple
playthroughs so first playthrough is
going to be all good
making all the
the good choices
and then a second playthrough as evil
which you know we don't even know how
that how much that's gonna be a thing
like will it affect I sure hope there
are multiple endings I sure hope so but
then I'm gonna be going for platinum
trophy and all that so I'm gonna be
playing a ton of the game finding all
the secrets those kinds of things
Lee says uh Mega let's play first and
then play it live in a house oh yeah I
read that one yep could film your First
Reactions without showing the actual
game and just show that oh no that's
I'm trying to picture how that will work
on YouTube
film your First Reactions without
showing the actual you have ah I don't
know then people wouldn't know
I feel like without the context of
what's going on it would just be weird
that Tater that is that is what I want
to have videos ready for exactly what
you just said when people need help with
the puzzles
that sort of thing
I want to have those videos ready to
rock and roll yeah
so that's why I'm not as certain about
I'm definitely going to be live
streaming
clear for 100 the question is when
and like what playthrough will it be
yeah
Jordan says one play through as
recordings second streamed
[Music]
if you get ahead of me well that seems
like a me bro
dude I'm gonna take a week off of work
for this for this game so I can just
lock in
uh Gryffindor Neil Gryffindor
if you get early press access hope they
do something special for contract
creators like eldering did oh what did
they do
I feel like I remember I know they I
know Eldon rig did something awesome for
the uh
let me solo her guy that was amazing
what they did for that guy
maybe give us the collection Edition I
doubt that I doubt that
and the reason I doubt it is because
James is still desperately James uh
expect to go is still desperately trying
to find one
so I feel like if they were gonna give
give us one
they should at least go ahead and tell
James so he's not scrambling to find one
sick of Hogwarts Legacy content not
possible
a lot of people don't care for spoils
and would watch that's true too Gabe
that's true and it could I feel like see
that's that's a
it's a good point Gabe because that also
gets me thinking about the audience of
people who
aren't as die-hard as like we are and
who are on the fence about the game like
we're buying it
if the game gets 4 out of 10 review
scores I don't care I'm still gonna buy
it and play it to make my own opinion
but there could be people who are on the
fence who are like hey I want to check
out some streams see what people are
saying about this see if people are
enjoying it seeing what it looks like
that's a good point too that's a good
point
eldering press addiction
press addiction press Edition came with
a manufactured sword oh my gosh
that is awesome
that is awesome
off days are lined up with the game
that's always nice Ryan says playthrough
with outstream first make the videos you
want to post then do play that's sort of
what I'm leaning toward
but I would love to be able to do it in
advance
of the game releasing
and then be able to stream live the day
the game comes out too
because then like that's the best of
both worlds
oh it's gonna be such an exciting time
such an exciting time
because I don't want to miss I mean
with the live streams it's like you
could there's gonna be a window
where way more people than just us the
hardcore are interested where the
mainstream eyes will be turned to the
game for a bit
[Music]
and that's when it could be beneficial
to be on a twitch versus YouTube in
terms of live streams
but I don't know I don't know we still
got a lot of time we still got a lot of
time to think about it
after cyberpunk at Fallout 76 reverse
myself to not trust reviewers anymore
yeah
so I could see people definitely being a
little more interested in
streams and stuff
can't see how it'll be anything less
than a 7 out of 10 looks very well built
gameplay wise we'll see gameplay Thomas
I feel like that's what we still know so
little about
we don't know how well it's gonna run we
don't know frame rate we don't know the
moment to moment gameplay of like the
spell casting all that that's the
biggest thing I still want to see
all the other stuff I'm like story
whatever you guys want to do
story I'll see it when the game comes
out I don't need to see anything about
that I don't need to know about all the
secrets all the exploration I know
they're gonna nail that I I feel very
confident they're gonna nail the
exploration
finding Secrets all that stuff nail I
think they'll 100 nail it the combat
though
we don't know yet we don't know
uh Nat's night it might not be a game
Everyone likes playing but they might
enjoy lore that's a good point too yep
Nico talking about oh yeah that I think
chat choosing a dialogue that's a good
one for
like a second or third play through yeah
getting Deluxe a few days before only a
few days I can't finish the game in that
time I know yeah
we don't who knows we don't know how
long the game is
yeah I'm gonna use the wand I got from
The Wizarding World quiz Noob yep I'm
pretty happy with my wand
I'm pretty sure it's uh
now you got me second guessing
I'm pretty sure it was
let's see here
I know it's uh phoenix feather
and I think it's Beachwood
yeah it's Beach
wood
[Music]
Beachwood Phoenix core 12 and 1 4
unbending flexibility
toward a shell cat don't even get me
started chat don't even get me started
not happy with my Patronus
not happy with it it's like the second
or third I think it's the
I think it's just the second time I've
gotten it
CJ happy to be here jumping back to the
start hey
enjoy the replay CJ
seems so close yet so far away right
it would be great for you to have
content rollouts and then live streams
are just live yeah
do open world exploration exploration
streams where you don't touch the story
true true
massive quidditch fan I hope the sport
gets its own full multiplayer game
[Music]
what people want after Hogwarts Legacy
because there's a large portion of the
fan base that
keeps one in quidditch I definitely
think there's enough
enough support for it I wonder if it
would be its own game if it would be a
DLC
foreign
I don't know I don't know because to me
like At first I thought oh it makes
perfect sense for a DLC
but then if Hogwarts Legacy man if it
delivers if it does what I think it can
do
I don't want them to work on a quidditch
DLC I want them to give me like a summer
story DLC for my character
where we're outside of Hogwarts in the
summer
like could you imagine a
I'm going way Pie in the Sky here I know
but let's just let's just dream big for
a minute
because like DLC that's kind of like a
dirty word people hate like DLC why
wouldn't you put it in the regular game
it has to be something that goes like
Beyond which the core game you know so
the core Hogwarts Legacy gives us a
complete experience where we go through
the school year we have an amazing story
that story comes to a close our
character gets the end of the school
year
and then think about an amazing DLC
would be
what about a summer internship at the
ministry
and you're like I don't know you're
interning with borrowers and you're
interning with
people working in the
um
oh what's it called
Department of mysteries
you're like learning all because you're
you know we assume you're pretty new to
The Wizarding World
we think because your character is gonna
have to be play catch up and all this
oh I mean there's so many it doesn't
have to be industry magic there's so
many possibilities you can do like an
Azkaban DLC although I still think I
still think Azkaban is going to be in
the main game I do I do I think it's
going to be there somewhere
so like when I start thinking about all
those possibilities I'm like ah
quidditch keeps getting shifted down the
list
I I gotta keep shifting that one down
the list I'm sorry I'm sorry I know a
lot of people want it
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Colby Ministry magic DLC
would be amazing
foreign
11 and a half quite bendy ebony with
unicorn hair
hummingbird Patronus man I've been
hearing of so many people there was
somebody in a YouTube comment that
talked about getting the a field mouse
for Patronus like I didn't even know you
could the Patronus this could be that
small
so a hummingbird and a field mouse I
almost would rather have a hummingbird
than a tortoiseshell cat
and it's no offense to cats it's just
I'm highly allergic to cats dude highly
allergic to them
foreign
yeah I feel pretty good about it Ryan I
think
at least
they showed it in the trailer
don't show it in the trailer unless
we're gonna be going there
or at least a mission
Hogwarts Legacy one two three might have
different titles yeah Red Dead Revolver
Red Dead Redemption
oh man let me see what uh
I had something else in the title for
things that I wanted to cover tonight
and I don't even I don't even remember
if we uh
if I covered everything wait is it not
show on my phone
what it doesn't
okay maybe I have to go not in the
YouTube studio app
uh your channel okay
new Instagram post plus Hogwarts Legacy
gameplay oh yeah
by the way chandlerwood also teased
gameplay coming soon
within the next three months for sure he
definitely said before 2023
we did we talked about that a little bit
we did we did I was hoping we'd have
time tonight to do a um
I'm definitely gonna work on I haven't
made the video for it yet because I've
been honestly agonizing internally over
my next common room tier list video been
agonizing a bit over it I can't decide
I can't decide where I want to place
things
I I'm trying to decide how I want to
rate them
and then where I want to place them
I'll just give you guys a little sneak
peek though they're all eightier bare
minimum minimum a tier
I just I I don't feel like there's a bad
Common room I think they're all if I was
in the respective house I would love I
would love I would love my common room
so I don't think any of them are bad
which kind of makes it even harder like
if there was one that was clearly not
that great then the tier list would be
easier for me to make but
I don't know maybe we'll save that for
next week
I'm Maury poet Ravenclaw best hands down
Gryffindor is the best Tater says I'm
biased Noob agrees with Amore poet
JP raven fire throwing them all out
there Nico your Patronus is a ginger cat
I mean I don't dislike cat I actually
I'd like cats I would have a cat
probably if I wasn't so highly allergic
to them
and my wife's just not a fan of cats
either so
it's never it's just never been an issue
with us
somebody was complaining though I can't
remember where I saw this was it was
Twitter or YouTube comment or something
they were complaining about getting a
West Highland Terrier a wet that's a
Westie that's my dog
let's think it I would have loved to
have gotten that as my Patronus
hippocrite see hippogriff man that would
be cool
I I took another test
where I did like all the Patronus
questions and I got a dolphin on that
one so and dolphin has always been one
of my favorite animals so I feel like
dolphin is my is my true Patronus
regardless of what the Wizarding World
may say
got a rare one I cheated on my Patronus
I had to do dealing with the possibility
of it coming into the game right
that still is pretty good too yeah
Osprey oh that's definitely a cool one
read to I got a weasel
SMH
oh man
it's just like when somebody can get a
dragon and then you get a field mouse or
a Somebody by somebody said hummingbird
weasel it's like come on
really
really they get a dragon I get a field
mouse
could you imagine how upset you would be
in the Wizarding World
same thing with becoming an anime guy
like
you don't get to pick your animal right
I mean Sirius gets a dog pretty cool
James gets a stag and then wormtails a
rat
if that if that wasn't a clue enough for
them not to make him the Secret Keeper
come on James come on dude it should
have been so obvious
at that point
his anime just is a rat come on
[Music]
oh goodness Eagle I like Eagle that's
pretty cool camel like see Campbell I've
never I've never seen that one oh you
got the West Highland Terrier I pulled
up nice
squirrel I think I'd almost rather have
a squirrel than a
the tortoiseshell cat that I got
a Rottweiler
peacock see there's so many there's so
many Patronus in there that's why I
don't think it will be I don't think
they'll carry over in the game even if
expected patronum is in the game I don't
think it'll carry over
all right guys we are coming up on the 2
hour and 41 minute Mark so if you didn't
already
check out today's video
leave a comment letting me know
which
three questions or not even three
questions what are the big questions
that you guys still want answered about
Hogwarts Legacy
I did three of the biggest questions
that I still have is this one right here
Hogwarts I guess he still needs to
answer these questions
so my three big ones were how does the
time system work
you watched already Noob nice
yeah I figured a lot of you if you're
hearing the live stream you probably
already watched already
how does the the timing in the game work
how does how do spells work in the game
and then also how who is the Ravenclaw
companion
those are three of the big ones that I
have
so leave a comment letting me know what
you guys think
and then if you missed it if you're kind
of just uh getting into the stream late
this was our main topic of discussion
tonight I do not use Instagram a lot I'm
not sure why
that Hogwarts Legacy they have only
posted this on the Instagram
an unauthorized guide to Hogwarts
little comment here don't tell the
Headmaster consider this an unauthorized
guide
this right here as well common room
secrets we talked about all this on the
stream if you're just now jumping in you
can go back re-watch check that out
there
and see what all we talked about
because there was a lot
there was a lot we went back and we also
found
some
moments in the trailer where you can see
that book
you can see that book in the Gameplay
trailer as well
so check all that out we'll be back
again next week I think we're gonna go
ahead and
switch over to the full cam view here
[Music]
and I appreciate you guys man just a
crazy amount of support tonight a
ridiculous amount of
new
um members we had a crazy amount of
gifted Subs I'm just looking at the
numbers now we had 20 new channel
members tonight between gifts and
between people joining up for the first
time that is insane
oh my gosh that's good it bothers me
that I see this wobbling in the shot
I need to quit leaning on my table if I
don't lean on the table then it doesn't
do it as much
20 new members though that is insane
we're definitely going to be getting
some new emoji
new emoji on the way
because we unlocked at least four but
potentially more
potentially more off the double check
and see
so we're gonna have
we're gonna have a high and I need to
think
let me know right now
let me know right now before you hop off
if you have a good idea of what the wave
Emoji should be
I want to have like a way an emoji that
you could use when you're when you hop
into the stream and you just want to
like say hello
we need a good we could do another house
elf one but I kind of want to do
something different
I kind of want to do a different
character inspired
so here's the ones that we have right
now I'm just gonna paste them all
in the Stream
there you go in the chat rather
Hagrid waving I like the idea of Hagrid
and see Emoji are so small it has to be
something that's like I like the voldi
the house elf and the the Hat are so
easy to see the Merlin one I like the
Merlin one but it's like the Merlin one
is super hard for me to see I don't know
maybe it's easier on mobile but looking
at it on a big screen it's a little bit
harder to tell than Merlin
I guess we could do Merlin waving
that's an idea
foreign
doing something yeah a wand is something
that's simple that's I thought about
something with a broomstick too
[Music]
McGonagall tipping her hat
yeah if you guys look in the chat there
you can see how the the simple ones
always work better
[Music]
the stick that waves in Fantastic Beasts
oh
Bo chuckle
a bow chuckle might be a really good one
I could see that being a
I could I'm trying to picture that
because you have to make the Expressions
be very clear for the emotes
to really stand out
I'm gonna I'm gonna put that into my
notes
Emoji ideas
[Music]
oh chuckle I like that I like that one
for sure
and I'm gonna say I'm gonna say waving
for now
but I could do something else with a bow
truckle too
yeah we could do the house self waving
too that's another option
something with a wand okay I'm seeing a
lot of wand suggestions
wand with lumos
[Music]
lumos maxima
niffler with a coin
oh
my gosh my phone just auto corrected
niffler to Muffler
no I actually want to type niffler thank
you
that one that one's going in for sure
like when people Super Chat
when people donate we could like throw
up the niffler
broom possibility
Thunderbolt not Thunderbolt Fireball
the shrunken heads dark mark
Puri incantatum yeah that one might be a
little small
a sock
master has presented Dobby with a suck
hey have a good night Stephen thank you
for hanging out
the over morning house emojis
[Music]
and I could always do like somebody back
when we made the ones that I the newer
ones somebody has suggested in addition
to the laughing or the angry Voldemort
we have a laughing Voldemort which I
love that idea I might do that one too
we've got a couple slots so we got we
can play around with it a bit
all right guys this has been a blast
thank you all so much for hanging out uh
if you want to stick around and support
the stream a little bit I'm gonna hit
the end screen and then I'll do a little
uh I'll hit the add button
feel free to head out
uh this this will stay up as of odd so
if you guys missed any part of this you
can go back and watch it uh but yeah man
keep an eye out on the channel gonna
have at least one more other video
hitting this week
and yeah we'll go from there we'll see
what next week's live stream holds I
definitely want to do another live
stream for a game as well so we might
play Chamber of Secrets PC again I've I
researched online and found some ways to
get it running at high resolution so it
looks so so much better
so much better than it did before
and it actually let me see my chat
correctly as well I tested it with obs2
so
we'll see we'll see what what news the
week brings though we might get more
Hogwarts Legacy news you never know
which Chandler would in these guys they
dropped some things when we least expect
it
all right guys thank you all for being
here thank you all for the crazy support
as always thank you all so much for
watching
I'll talk to you again soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]